it's just like Ted hello acquit me to
cock-block who does that he does that
it's a problem stop
oh no it's Margaret not good she is
obsessed with me yeah Oh it's insane
like every time I come to this bar she's
like hey I'm just like hey can't you see
I'm just trying to hang out with my
friends you know it's guys night out
take it easy ah just go ahead
ignore her Zak okay she's in love with
me I feel embarrassed for her you know
what I'm saying I just want to like save
her some face on the girl band there
would be like hey girl listen like
plenty other fish in the sea you don't
have to go for this forbidden fruit you
want to try someone else anyone except
me you know I actually think she's
waving at me
don't be ridiculous actually is in love
with me oh that's cute
hi hi I'm I'm Margaret uh I'm Zak nice
to meet you oh boy here we go
classic marker just waltzing over trying
to get to me through my friends am i
bothering you again Justin yeah Margaret
as a matter of fact you are and to be
quite frank it's getting old
I'm flattered that you're so enamored
with me but it's never gonna oh my god
Justin please get over yourself I'm not
interested in you I'm never interested
in you it's always your cute friends and
you always cock-block me every single
time you know what I'm gonna give my
number Zach call me anytime just leave
just now yeah yeah it's a shame the
girls obsessive yeah I could have been
my dream girl